How many alternate timelines do you destroy
the world because frankly you don't have
the cojones to die yourself what are we
holding up somewhere he'll never suspect
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
justice league snyder cut ending video for all the
different end credit scenes it's basically a giant
epilogue that's very different from the theatrical
cut that's setting up a whole bunch of other stuff
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos i will be doing more full
breakdown videos the movie's over four hours long
so there is a lot of brand new stuff to talk about
but careful for spoilers if you have not seen
the movie yet if you haven't seen the snyder cut
but just starting at the end of the movie the
three mother boxes unite to form the unity setting
off this chain reaction that's going to terraform
the planet into another version of apocalypse that
you see in the nightmare flash forwards there are
a couple different nightmare flash forwards that
i'll talk about during this tooth they reference
the flash is able to use the speed force to time
travel to prevent it from happening in a sort of
rewind scene where you do see it unfold like it
actually happens but then as the flash starts
running into super speed into the speed force
everything rewinds you see everyone's body parts
flying back onto their bodies including superman's
then the justice league of superman defeats
steppenwolf aquaman runs him through with his
mother's trident superman punches him through the
boom tube that's now open with darkseid d'assad
and granny goodness watching all this unfold
watching steppenwolf get killed wonder woman
chops his head off with her sword as his body is
flying through the boom tube and darkseid stops
his head with his boot then crushes it then they
have this classic gunslinger standoff moment with
darkseid staring down the justice league in black
suit superman but after the boom tube closes you
switch to darkseid's perspective on apocalypse
d'assad asks him what his plan is now that the
three mother boxes have been destroyed the great
prize that he's referring to is the anti-life
equation that they referenced several times during
the movie which is on earth they find that's what
the giant symbol is when they crack the ground in
the dark side war flashback and when steppenwolf
is given the vision by the mother boxes i've
seen it with my own eyes carved into the very
face of this planet darkseid says he's going to
use it to take control of the entire multiverse
so they also set up the concept of the multiverse
during the justice league snyder cut we'll see the
multiverse during the flash movie but it's a very
different version of the flash movie than they
were originally planning on making when they shot
this scene with darkseid and assad darkseid says
they'll obtain the anti-life equation at any
cost and they'll go and do things the old way
the old ways that he's referring to is a callback
to the flashback scene earlier in the movie
thousands of years ago when he tried to take earth
and lost to the combined forces of the humans the
amazons the old gods the atlanteans in the green
lantern corps he got his ass beat by the old gods
bad zeus and ares mostly ares almost took his
entire arm off during that flashback wonder woman
explains the dark side used to fly around planet
to planet one at a time with his armada conquering
them with the mother boxes but in present day the
new ways is basically just the quieter stealthier
way darkseid's sending steppenwolf to do most of
the busy work of conquering the universe for him
looking for the anti-life equation and covering
his debt for trying to usurp the throne of
apocalypse for him that was the history that
they were referring to they didn't explicitly
state what he did to betray darkseid but you kind
of get what was going on like oh he tried to steal
the throne of apocalypse from darkseid at one
point in the past still have 50 000 worlds to
conquer on his sentence but remember these beings
are so powerful they're functionally immortal
so unless you kill them like they do during
the movie they'll just keep on living forever
pretty much there is a new gods movie that they're
going to be making that darkseid will be featured
during but is eva duvernay and tom king basing it
on tom king's mr miracle run so it'll be a very
different looking version of all these characters
than you saw during zack snyder's justice league
so darkseid is headed to earth with his giant
fleet for the sequels justice league 2 and then
they have a bunch of alternate versions of those
ending scenes and post credit scenes with all the
different justice league characters that were
meant to actually set up their sequels and solo
movies that were coming right after this because
like 99 of this footage and all these ending
scenes and post credit scenes was shot by zack
snyder way back in 2016 and 2017 before he left
the project the official title of the epilogue
is a father twice over which is a reference to
cyborg's father calling himself his father twice
over because he was born to him and his mother as
a child the old-fashioned way but then he ushered
his rebirth his second birth as the cyborg with
the mother box and we did get a full version of
that origin story during the movie you actually
see cyborg explain how his father used the mother
box to repair his body you get a whole bunch of
footage cyborg probably had the biggest story
upgrade of any of the characters next to like
steppenwolf and darkseid during the snyder cut
i'll talk more about him during my full breakdown
video for the movie but it's his father's
voiceover in the tape recording that he repairs
that replaces the entire lois lane speech at the
end of the theatrical cut over all these scenes
ryan choi becomes the new head of star labs i'm
sure he would have probably come back during the
flash movie as part of the star lab storyline they
originally intended on making at that point and
then the cyborg solo movie to become a version
of the atom from the comics because they say he
works in nanotechnology that was just a reference
to him eventually becoming the adam then you get
the aquaman scene with him saying goodbye to
volcko and mira and he goes to see his father
obviously they were getting ready to
make the aquaman solo movie at this point
he has this really long look with mira setting up
their eventual romance and relationship that they
paid off during the actual aquaman movie that we
saw vulco also had a big upgrade during the snyder
cut there were a ton more atlanta scenes with
those characters obviously they also changed a lot
of the looks and the designs for the characters
when they got to some of these solo movies they
have a similar version of the batman wonder woman
scene at wayne manor where he talks about turning
it into the hall of justice that's actually what
you see the rebel of in the nightmare scene with
superman flying over it holding batman's cowl this
one was from cyborg's vision from the mother boxes
the mother boxes show him a vision of a possible
future when he interfaces with it while they're
resurrecting superman i'll get into this in a
second though they have this whole concept of
multiple timelines that the joker references in
one of the post-credits scenes but this is the
timeline where superman winds up killing most of
the justice league for darkseid but it was just a
possible future the actual nightmare post-credit
scene plays out a little bit differently
the scene of batman telling superman about
buying the bank that owned the kent farm
is pretty much the same then you see a new scene
of batman and gotham city in his costume on top
of the bat tank it looks like a very frank miller
dark knight returns inspired batman tank very cool
looking and probably something that would have
showed up during the version of the batman movie
he was doing we also get a brand new scene of
cyborg visiting his father's grave then taking off
taking his spot amongst the brave ones like taking
his spot on the justice league so to speak as they
were implying in the sequels and then the new
scene of wonder woman looking out over the cliff
of that amazonian temple from earlier in the movie
with the warning arrow that's all supposed to set
up her sequel storyline that zack snyder and jim
lee outlined in their pitch document remember
earlier in the movie how steppenwolf taunted her
saying she'd abandoned her sisters on themscara
you weren't there to protect them this scene
was supposed to set up the idea that she finds
a way back to themyscira during the sequels and
eventually was supposed to replace hippolyta
as queen of the amazons in justice league 2 in
justice league 3. superman seen here taking off
is pretty much the same with one minor change he's
still wearing the black suit and obviously the
voice over is from cyborg's father and not lois
lane but he would have eventually gone on to a
direct sequel to the first man of steel movie zack
snyder was also teasing that lois lane might be
pregnant earlier in the movie he doesn't outline
the major plotline of what man of steel 2 would
have been or anything like that but clearly they
were hyping up the idea of baby john kent from the
comics also the baby itself would have played into
the idea of darkseid breaking superman in justice
league 2 when he kills lois lane in that nightmare
vision of cyborgs but then the lex luthor post
credit scene is totally different you see a much
longer version of his breakout from arkham asylum
with the help of deathstroke this is all meant to
set up ben affleck's version of the batman movie
because he tells deathstroke batman's secret
identity as bruce wayne why are you doing this for
free because it's personal oh an eye for an eye
i see so it's meant to set up this history that
deathstroke has with batman and he was going to
be the main villain of ben affleck's batman movie
it would have been a riddler hush type of scenario
where you have a batman villain that learns his
secret identity then just systematically goes
around trying to destroy his life per zack
snyder's justice league 2 and justice league 3
story pitch lex luthor would have gone on to make
a deal with darkseid forming his own injustice
league with a bunch of the villains from the
solo movies the members of his injustice league
would have been the riddler in deathstroke so
the riddler would have also been a big character
during ben affleck's batman movie funny that he's
also a big character during matt reeve's batman
movie with robert pattinson then dr poison from
the wonder woman movie captain cold from the flash
movie that they were doing at that point i don't
know if captain cold is still going to be in the
new version of the flash movie then orm in black
manta from the aquaman movie but then you have
the new nightmare post credit scene and it's meant
to be a flash forward to what actually winds up
happening so you see a slightly different version
than what cyborg's vision was where lois lane
has still died superman still falls to darkseid's
influence turns evil and then a hodgepodge group
of justice league survivors and villains start
working together the person that they reference
they're hiding from is evil superman not darkseid
who does end up finding them a few minutes later
anyway but it's batman Mera cyborg the flash
who's wearing his time travel suit because he was
actually going to time travel back into the past
to warn bruce in the sequels deathstroke and jared
leto's joker batman says he's taking them to a
place where superman will never think to look he's
probably talking about the former hall of justice
wayne manor then mera starts it up with batman
because she doesn't think that he cares about
how superman killed aquaman and she wants
revenge so bad so they do reveal that this
version of superman did kill aquaman then joker
pipes in taunting batman explaining that he does
understand what it's like to lose people he loves
he references his parents dying in crime alley
then they really get into it when he references
the dead robin that he and harley quinn killed why
did you send a boy to do a man's job so he spends
a good couple of minutes taunting batman and zack
snyder did explain that he has plans to do a
comic book with jim lee at some point where they
actually tell the backstory of that dead robin but
zack snyder's version of robin isn't jason todd it
was actually meant to be grayson that died batman
drops an f-bomb telling joker he's going to kill
him for sure at some point the second one in the
movie cyborg had the first f-bomb when he first
met wonder woman so there are two in the movie
they form a truce when joker gives him his playing
card for the duration of their plan here to save
the world using flash's time travel but joker also
explains the idea of the multiple timelines saying
that in all these other timelines batman hasn't
had the guts to die himself he keeps sending other
people to do the dirty work for him that was meant
to set up batman's eventual sacrifice in justice
league three where batman is the one that winds up
dying to save the rest of the justice league in a
sort of twist on superman's sacrifice in batman v
superman so that's why they have that particular
dialogue here there's also some talk about
reach-arounds i don't know what's going on with
that but batman also reveals that harley quinn
died in his arms at some point in this nightmare
future this post-apocalyptic future and begged
him to kill joker slowly then they all start
talking about how they need to get moving or
evil superman is going to find them boom just as
he does find them he lands you see his eyes start
glowing red and he's wearing the blue suit now
but just as they get ready to fight batman wakes
up again as if he's having another nightmare it's
a very similar type of scene is when he woke up
in the batcave with the first nightmare scene
back in batman v superman but he wakes back up
in present day after they've defeated steppenwolf
where everything's still pretty chill and martian
manhunter shows up at his lake house to reveal
himself and that he's going to fight with them
in the sequels so this is just paying off some
of the earlier martian manhunter scenes from
previously in the movie and it sounds like based
on the storyboard zack snyder always planned on
including a version of martian manhunter but this
particular post credit scene is brand new for the
snyder cut originally it was going to be two green
lanterns coming to visit batman at his lake house
i believe it was supposed to be killwog and tomar
ray and they were going to set up the justice
league 2 justice league 3 green lantern course
storyline in the idea of the hal jordan character
showing up eventually and we did see a version
of a dead green lantern in cyborg's vision of
the nightmare future the full green lantern corps
would have rolled in by justice league 3 but we
were going to see more than during justice league
2 but basically all of justice league 2 would have
been a nightmare movie would have all taken place
in this post-apocalyptic future so i'll talk more
about that the sequel ideas and the other things
he revealed about what was going to happen in the
stories for justice league 2 justice league 3 when
i do my full breakdown video later this weekend
that should post by saturday or sunday if there's
any other big easter eggs or things that i didn't
address from the ending of the movie that you
want to talk about just write them below in the
comments what will happen next is my falcon and
winter soldier episode one video is going to post
friday morning those videos will post every friday
just like my one division videos will you wait for
everything everyone click here for that nightmare
vision of darkseid going around killing all the
members of the justice league and click here for
my brand new falcon and winter soldier episode 1
trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!